SPECIAL REPORT.
MORE WITH THE PANEL LATER.
BACK HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
THE LIKELIHOOD OF A SUMMIT
BETWEEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
KIM JONG UN SEEMS TO BE GROWING
BY THE DAY.
A TOP NORTH KOREAN OFFICIAL HAS
BEEN DISPATCHED TO NEW YORK AND
HE WILL MEET WITH AMERICA’S TOP
DIPLOMAT WEDNESDAY.
ALL OF THIS COMES LESS THAN A
WEEK AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
CANCELED THE PLANNED SINGAPORE
SUMMIT.
CHIEF WHITE HORSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS IS HERE WITH ME ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS GETTING
READY TO DECLARE THE SUMMIT BACK
ON, AND EVEN IF IT IS BACK ON,
IT MIGHT BE IMPOSSIBLE TO HOLD
IT ON.
JUNE 12TH MAY BE SLID BACK A
COUPLE OF DAYS THAT THE PLANNING
IS PROCEEDING WITH FULL STEAM
AHEAD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAINTAINED TODAY
THAT HIS UPBEAT ASSESSMENT OF
THE SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG UN,
TWEETING THIS MORNING THAT ONE
OF THE HIGHEST RANKING OFFICIALS
IN NORTH KOREA WAS HEADED TO THE
U.S.
CONJUNCT HOLE, THE VICE CHAIRMAN
OF NORTH KOREA IS NOW HEADED TO
NEW YORK.
SOLID RESPONSE TO MY LETTER,
THANK YOU.
HE WAS THE HEAD OF NORTH KOREA’S
CYBER SPYING AGENCY AND WAS
SANCTIONED BY THE OBAMA
ALLEGEDLY ORCHESTRATING THE HACK
ATTACK ON SONY PICTURES.
HE WAS ALSO AT THE SIDE OF
KIM JONG UN AND UNA’S SIDE.
THIS HAPPENED AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S SHOCKED THE
WORLD AFTER SENDING HIM A LETTER
CALLING OUT THE SUMMIT.
>> I THINK HE REALLY GOT SOME
KINETIC ENERGY FLOWING.
FOLKS ALL OF A SUDDEN SAID, THIS
ACTUALLY DID NOT HAPPEN AND IF
YOU WANTED TO HAPPEN, WE HAVE TO
START MOVING.
THEY HAVE BEEN MAKING VERY
POSITIVE MOVES.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION HAS TWO
TEAMS IN THE REGION, ONE LED BY
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF JOE HAGAN
IS IN SINGAPORE TO WORK OUT THE
LOGISTICS OF THE POSSIBLE SUMMI
SUMMIT.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
WILL MEET IN NEW YORK TOMORROW
WITH KIM A YOUNG TROLL.
>> WE ARE STILL FINALIZING
EXACTLY WHAT THAT WILL LOOK
LIKE, AND RETURNING SOMETIME ON
THURSDAY.
I THINK IT’S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE
LOOKING AT WHERE WE WERE SIX
MONTHS AGO, AND NOW WE HAVE
OTHER THINGS TAKING PLACE.
THEY WILL HAVE MEETINGS WITH
JAPANESE PRIME MINISTER AND THEY
WILL VISIT THE WHITE HOUSE NEXT
THURSDAY.
THE THREAT FROM NORTH KOREA’S
INTERMEDIATE IMMEDIATE BALLISTIC
MISSILES AND JAPANESE CITIZENS
KIDNAPPED BY NORTH KOREA.
AT THEIR MAR-A-LAGO SUMMIT IN
APRIL, PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISED
HE WOULD RAISE IT.
>> President Trump: WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO HAVE THEM
BROUGHT BACK AND BRING THEM BACK
FROM JAPAN.
I GIVE YOU THAT PROMISE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SOUGHT
THE PRESIDENT’S HELP, BUT THE
WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCED IT WILL
SOON IMPOSE A 25% TARIFF ON
50 BILLION IN CHINESE AND PLUM,
IMPORTS CHINA RESPONDED TERSELY
TO WHAT IT SAW AS A NEGOTIATING
A TACTIC.
IN A STATEMENT THE MINISTRY OF
CONGRESS IS SAYING WE ARE
SURPRISED BY THE STRATEGIC
STATEMENT BEING RELEASED AT THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
IT IS SOMEWHAT EXPECTED.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP GOT SOME LOW
BACK AFTER A TWEET HE SENT OUT
ON MEMORIAL DAY WHERE HE POSTED,
ABBY MEMORIAL DAY.
THOSE WHO DIED FOR OUR GREAT
COUNTRY WOULD BE VERY HAPPY AND
PROUD AT HOW WELL OUR COUNTRY IS
DOING TODAY.
IT’S THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS FOR BLACKS AND HISPANIC
EVER AND WOMEN IN 18 YEARS.
THAT PROMPTED A SOBER RESPONSE
FROM THE FORMER CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF.
GENERAL MARTIN DEMPSEY TWEETED,
THIS DAY OF ALL DAYS OF THE YEAR
SHOULD NOT BE ABOUT ANY ONE OF
US.
NO MATTER HOW STRATEGIC OR
POWERFUL, NO MATTER HOW SIX
SUCCESSFUL WE PERCEIVE OURSELVES
TO BE.
THE PRESIDENT’S TONE WAS MUCH
DIFFERENT.
THE FIRST DAUGHTER, IVANKA     P
SEEM TO GET IT JUST
PITCH-PERFECT WHEN SHE TWEETED
OUT, AS WE REMEMBER OUR FALLING
MEN, ACADEMIC FALLING MEN AND
WOMEN, WE REMEMBER OUR GRATITUD
GRATITUDE.
>> ANOTHER ASPECT OF
IVANKA TRUMP RAISING SOME
EYEBROWS.
SHORTLY AFTER THAT, THE
PRESIDENT CUT A DEAL AND ABIGAIL
CLEM WHO RUNS THE IVANKA TRUMP
BRANDON SAID THAT IT WAS
BUSINESS AS USUAL.
AND THERE ARE SO MANY TRADEMARK
VIOLATIONS, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
POINTING OUT THAT WHILE THE
PRESIDENT DID CUT A DEAL, HE
ALSO THIS MORNING SAID HE WAS